bonjour à tous aujourd'hui ont des sms à
las vegas je sors tout juste 10 stand de
samsung qui est derrière
[Musique]
j'en ai profité pour discuter un petit
peu avec une personne responsable de
l'équipe de samsung qui m'a fait essayer
les nouveaux galaxy à 8 avec plus pour
lui poser la question est ce que le
samsung galaxy x pourrait voir le jour
est ce qu'il pourrait arriver cette
année est-ce qu'on ait une chance de le
voir il avoir dans les mains ce qui se
produit pour exister
alors c'est vrai que pour l'instant la
réponse et reste toujours très évasive
on vous dira oh je ne sais pas a priori
mais dans l'absolu
j'ai plutôt l'impression qu'on se dirige
vers un nom pour le moment parce qu'elle
m'a dit aujourd'hui le galaxy x tel
qu'il a été prévu en tout cas il ya des
années a vraiment les spécifications du
s suit donc pour l'instant pas
particulièrement de deux galaxies en
prévision alors j'ai aussi posé la
question à savoir est ce qu on pourrait
avoir des écrans prière à l'avenir
là-dessus la réponse est un peu plus
évasif un diacre la première et
dirigeants mais on m'a dit que là dessus
y avait un vrai secret y avait
absolument aucune information qui
sortait en aucune façon je me doutais
qu'on n'avait pas mis un terme bien sûr
j'ai le calacs 6 dans la poche
tiens pour le tue pas les sags et à
bâtir et je vous montrais nouveau
prototype je ne vous ai clairement
j'allais pas ces informations par contre
j'ai l'impression que le galaxy x en
tout cas sous le nom de galaxy x risque
pas forcément de voir un jour par contre
les écrans pliables on risque de les
voir arriver très prochainement
alors peut-être que le galaxy x a été
roger portet qui aura soin notre nom
soit qui arrivera avec les évolutions
des sports avec les évolutions des
autres smartphones comme le suit et les
suites plus sur autre chose sur un autre
modèle saas est complètement possible
c'est vrai que pour l'instant on n'a pas
plus la formation j'aurais vraiment aimé
pour vous en dire plus récupérer plus
d'infos allez à la pêche aux infos bon
voilà ça c'est un petit peu compliqué
par contre ce que je vois et ce que je
ressens c'est que le galaxy x sinon x on
ne verra pas par contre les écrans
pliables
on va les avoir on va se régaler et
d'ici quelques temps 2018 je ne sais pas
j'ai bon espoir pour 2019 peut-être 2020
de toute façon les grandes marques
doivent se venger cette problématique
donc ça va être vraiment très
intéressante dites moi tout ce que vous
en pensez en commentaire est-ce que vous
pensez que ça pourrait arriver un peu
même
est-ce que vous pensez que ça peut
arriver est ce que ça vous intéresse
mark et moi tout en commentaire on en
discute ensemble et de toute façon on
reste connectés
si j'ai des enfants aussi je vois des
choses on reste connectés et si je vois
des choses s'il ya des bonnes infos je
manquerai pas de vous le dire
donc restez connectés abonnez vous
mettez-moi tous vos commentaires des
jolis pouces n'oubliez pas que vous aime
et on continue c est parce qu on a plein
de nouveautés à voir cette année et on
se régale